Dr. Burke here. Today we're going to
talk about how to strengthen your legs.
Now, this is not just a general video on
to make your legs stronger. This has to
do with increasing your longevity, your
legs, and the strength and what they can
do to support you. It's one of the best
indicators to know how long you're going
to live because the legs give you a lot
of early warning signs on what's going
on with more dangerous conditions in
your body. So, this becomes more
relevant the older you are. So, if
you're over 50, you need to be watching
this video. So, if you're under 50,
watch it as well because you want to
know how to prevent problems and use the
legs as a good way to determine if
there's a problem throughout the body.
Let's start with number one. There's
something called peripheral neuropathy.
That's usually in a situation when you
have diabetes. And what happens with
diabetes is you have this high level of
sugar in the bloodstream that destroys
the vascular system and then also the
nervous system. And this is because high
levels of sugar are toxic. Now, the
reason why people with diabetes start to
get numbness or pain or tingling or
burning in the bottom of their feet
first, sometimes in their fingertips, is
because of this. You have this super
long nerve and the further that nerve is
away from the heart, the more it's going
to show up as a problem because it's
getting a little less oxygen, blood
flow, and nutrition compared to tissues
that are closer to the heart. When you
have this peripheral neuropathy which is
on the bottom of your feet, you have to
realize what's going on. This is a blood
sugar problem. Probably you have either
pre-diabetes or diabetes. And normally
the body has a very tight control over
blood sugar. Like normal sugar in all of
your blood should only be one teaspoon
of sugar. And if you include all the
starches, you're talking between 50 to
100 teaspoons of sugar, including the
hidden sugar as well that are going
through your body. And so if normal
blood sugar is one teaspoon, you can
imagine what all that sugar is doing to
the arteries and what your body's doing
to remove that sugar. It's removing it
like crazy with a vacuum cleaner called
insulin. And so normal sugar is one
teaspoon, but diabetes
is only two teaspoons of sugar. And so
what does all that mean? It means that
the body doesn't like sugar in the
blood. So it's going to remove it. But
when you have two teaspoons of sugar,
you have a problem with insulin. Either
there's so much resistance with insulin,
it can't really work anymore, or the
pancreas is so exhausted, it's tired, it
can't put out as much insulin, you no
longer have the vacuum cleaner to suck
it out. So the blood sugar goes high and
that is where you get all the artery
problems, okay, that I'm going to be
talking about, especially it's going to
show up in the bottom of your foot. So
too much sugar is like really deadly for
your circulation as well as the nerves.
All right, let's go to number two. Ankle
and foot edema. You know, when I'm
traveling somewhere or I'm visiting
somewhere, I always see someone wearing
sandals or even shoes with the bottom of
their foot just being like completely
swollen. and I can see the bottom of
their legs completely puffy and I want
to walk up to them but I don't. But
those people have some serious edema
going on. If you were to press into the
ankle it would leave an indentation and
it' be stuck there. That's called
pitting edema. And that's not a little
thing. That's a big problem. Or they'll
take their socks off and they'll leave
this serious indentation around the
lower legs. Now what's really bizarre is
I had a version of this. I had pitting
edema in the earlier part of my life
which is just wild to think that I had
that. But this is indication that the
circulation is so bad that it's affected
the kidney or the liver or the heart and
we're getting less oxygen to the bottom
of the feet because we're not able to
circulate this blood. It's just pooling
there. And think about how much stress
that puts on the heart because this is
how it works. We have the arterial
system, all the arteries that are
pushing blood out to your extremities to
your fingers and your toes. Okay? Then
they get to the end of this long chain
and then they go through these
capillaries, okay? Tiny little blood
vessels and then they cross over into
the Venus system and then the Venus
system is the return back up to the
heart, but it goes to the lungs, gets
reoxygenated, and then the cycle happens
again. If at the end of this chain, the
bottom of your foot, we have pooling of
blood or or fluid, that's a backup of
the system. That's a situation where the
heart is working extra hard to push
through that inertia. And so number two
is a really good indicator that you have
a much deeper problem and you should not
ignore it. You should do something about
it. And from my viewpoint, I think you
should do something more natural because
a lot of times what they'll do is
they'll just put you on a blood thinner
and then monitor it. Number three,
restless legs syndrome. What is that?
That's a situation where your legs
become very very restless usually at
night. I had this condition is driving
me crazy. I would get up at, you know,
four o'clock in the morning and just
have to pound my legs because they had
so much energy in them. I could not
relax. I couldn't sleep. Little did I
know the diet is responsible for this.
If you consume way too much sugar and
starch, I was doing a lot of ice cream.
I was doing alcohol at the time. What
happens is it really depletes certain
vitamins and it actually causes you to
build up too much lactic acid which
creates kind of a cramping sensation and
just a lack of circulation. Little did I
know there's a couple remedies for this.
Number one, change your diet. But the
other thing is to take vitamin B1. B1 is
a great solution. Also, magnesium. Both
of those in combination counter the
effect of this high sugar diet. But you
have to realize what created the
deficiency in the first place would be
B1 and magnesium. It was the high
refined carbohydrate diet. So both of
those actions, change the diet and take
this nutrition to resolve this. The
problem with restless leg syndrome is
that it keeps you up and it keeps you
from sleeping. And that lack of sleeping
shortens your lifespan. There's a
massive connection with a lack of sleep,
increasing your risk of heart attacks,
strokes. It puts you at risk for
diabetes because it increases cortisol.
Other than that, you're totally fine
with number three. Let's talk about
number four, deep vein thrombosis.
Thrombosis is like a blood clot. One of
the dangers for this is a clot breaking
off from your legs and going up into the
lungs. That's not good. It can actually
kill you. Over 90 to 95% of all heart
attacks and strokes are a clot more than
this plaquing that builds up in the
arteries. So, this is something to pay
attention to and it's something that's
really important because there's certain
things in your body that will increase
your risk of getting a clot. And I'm
going to cover those in the second part
of this. But two things, stress and then
we come back to this high carbohydrate
diet. Again, let's go to number five.
Peripheral artery disease. This is
artery disease that is not necessarily
around the heart. It's in other places
in your body too. And so we have
atherosclerosis,
hearting of the arteries that go beyond
just like the coronary artery of your
heart. And I'm going to get into a bit
more on what to do about that, but the
inside of your artery has this single
layer cell called the endothelial layer
of tissue. And it's a very key important
tissue to keep healthy because if you
don't, it's going to create a
constriction. You can create hardening
of the arteries. You're going to create
arteries that are more rigid. You're
going to start creating inflammation.
And then the body's going to come in
with a band-aid and try to heal it with
plaquing. That's the band-aid in there.
But also the bigger issue is the clot
formation. And that can actually break
off, go into the brain and create a
stroke. So a lot more people die of
clots. But with this situation, we're
talking about more plaquing. Let's go to
number six, chronic venus insufficiency.
When we're talking about the veins,
we're talking about a uh pooling of
blood in the veins. A lot of times this
is associated with being sedentary, not
able to get out there and exercise
because the thing about the veins is
that you need muscular movement to get
that blood back up to the heart. And so
many people are not moving enough. And
so the venus system is insufficient.
It's stagnant blood that puts more
pressure on the heart because the heart
has to work harder to push this blood.
And one interesting thing about this is
that you'll see in the lower part of the
legs and the ankles this discoloration.
There'll be different like little spots.
You'll see more of a browning effect.
You'll see hair loss. You'll see thinner
skin. You're going to definitely see
pitting edema. But what's happening is
we're getting a lack of oxygen in the
lower part of the legs. And this can
shorten your lifespan. Okay. And then
number seven, we get sarcopenia. This is
age related muscle loss. It's one of the
top predictors of mortality when you get
older just by losing muscle because your
muscle is a very important metabolic
organ. You have a lot of mitochondria.
That's the energy factories in there. It
helps you burn off sugar. And so when
you lose this muscle, you lose a very
important buffer for living longer. And
so this is a combination of of course
aging, poor diet, lack of the co-actors,
especially magnesium and vitamin D and
zinc, but also having more of a
sedentary lifestyle. But it's a
combination of animal protein and
exercise that helps you retain and
maintain muscle. But I'm telling you, as
you get older, you should learn from the
mistakes of others and do whatever you
can to maintain a consistent exercise
program as you get older and have a goal
of becoming more fit every single year
because you're going up against aging.
But what you want to do is you want to
build up like a buffer or an extra
reserve of fitness that will compensate
for this aging process that everyone has
to go through and hopefully maintain as
much muscle as you possibly can as you
age. Let's first talk about type 2
diabetes. That's relating to that
peripheral neuropathy that I talked
about, but it's also related to a lot of
the other things that I talked about
because the more problems you have with
your blood sugar, the more you're going
to have problems with the inside of your
arteries. And it's just bizarre to me
that when you go to the doctor and you
get diagnosed with diabetes, you are not
instantly told
to get on a low carb diet. Instead,
you're told, "We're going to manage your
blood sugar, and we're even going to
give you some glucose pills. If your
blood sugar goes too low, you take these
sugar pills to maintain it." So, it's
all about managing the downstream
effects of this underlying root cause,
which is basically eating too many
carbs. I mean, I don't want to get
sidetracked, but I will say that I don't
know if this is intentional. It probably
is. Everything in medicine is so siloed.
It's so intentionally keeping the cause
and effect relationship from being found
out about or hidden. We silo doctors.
They're highly specialized in this and
this and this, but we're not connecting
the dots between those silos. The whole
system is set up not to look at root
causes. They don't look at lifestyle
factors. They're managing the downstream
effects. And even in research, right,
everything is like, well, there's an
association. They can't be too positive
on this causes this, or they'll say,
let's do a screening for early detection
so then we can get you on medications
earlier. There's really no prevention
going on, unfortunately. But with type 2
diabetes, you must attempt to go on a
low carb diet and do intermittent
fasting, two meals a day or even one
meal a day. Why? Because there is
hardcore research to show that you can
reverse type two diabetes in 10 weeks if
you go low carb. But that's only one
thing you can improve. You can also
improve fatty liver. You can improve
your arterial system. You can improve
the circulation of your legs and
definitely this peripheral neuropathy.
two remedies that I recommend if you
have peripheral neuropathy which will
actually help heal the nerves on the
bottom of your foot or the fingertips.
Benotamine is one. If you buy some
benotamine, just take four pills spread
out through the day. It works like a
charm. And then alphalapoic acid. Both
of these are miraculous as far as
helping you reverse peripheral
neuropathy. Now, of course, you want to
get to the root cause, too. You want to
fix the diet as well. Let's talk about
the lymph system and the veins. So most
people that are sedentary are going to
get a pooling of fluid in the lower
extremities in their legs because the
heart doesn't necessarily push the venus
supply that happens with exercise or
movement. But there's a really cool
muscle. It's called the solius. That's
part of the calf muscle. This muscle is
very very unique. And there's a
gentleman who actually came up with the
soius push-up. This is something that
anyone can do, especially if they're
sedentary or they do a lot of sitting at
the computer. You could literally do a
solius push-up and create dramatic
effects on your blood sugar and also on
your circulation because you can
actually push the blood back up to the
heart and take the stress off the heart.
So, it's like a second heart in your
calf. What's unique about this muscle,
the solius, is it doesn't get tired. It
has incredible endurance. It's very
efficient. And I highly recommend you do
it when you're sitting. I'm going to
show you a video right now more on the
person who actually developed this so
you can understand how to do it. I want
you to picture your ankle joint.
Sometimes this is where it's good to to
have a friend who might put their their
hand both on the top of the foot and on
the front of the ankle, right where the
ankle is straightening up. So if you
picture the foot and the ankle coming
together, what you're really doing is
you're just straightening that joint.
You're straightening it out. And so
that's the motion that you should think
about. Okay? That'll help you avoid a
lot of mistakes that we'll talk about
later that I see some doctors putting
videos up for their patients are doing
incorrectly.
All right? So the next point is that as
you do that, picture that you're lightly
pressing against the ball of the foot,
which is where the toes insert into the
foot, that that MTP joint. Just press
lightly as that as you're straightening
up that ankle. That's a good thing. You
don't want to press too hard, otherwise
you you'll start to to use your upper
leg muscles. We want all of these
muscles in the thigh completely relaxed.
Then the next point is that you want to
do a smooth dynamic motion. The rate can
vary quite a bit. The but what we we
really want to think about is move it
such that you're going in a fluid motion
like I'm doing here with my leg. It's
just going up and down, up and down.
Very smooth fluid motion. Okay? Don't
jerk it. Okay? You don't need to jerk
and pause. Again, there's some some
points that that we'll talk about later.
>> One last thing I want to mention about
the muscles. Your muscles in a rest
position only consume 15% of the energy.
Your brain consumes 20% of the energy in
a resting state. And so if you're more
sedentary and you're eating a good
amount of calories and you're thinking,
"Oh, my muscles are going to burn these
off." It's only going to just tap into a
small percentage of that energy. Well,
15%. This is why it's so important to
exercise on a regular consistent basis.
Let's talk about sarcopenia for a
second. This is a condition as you get
older where the muscles start getting
smaller and smaller and smaller and you
get weaker and weaker. There's a
interesting test. It's called a sitting
rising test. And uh I'm going to show
you a video on this in a second, but
this is a test that's linked into
longevity. And after you watch the
video, I'm going to see if you can do
this. I would recommend doing it on a
surface that's not too slippery, but
you're basically going to go down on a
sitting position and then you're going
to try to stand up without using your
arms. So, let me just show you how to do
that right now. However, is there value
to being more graceful on getting up off
of the floor? Absolutely. It's an
indicator of having good just strength
in general, but especially your core and
hip strength. So, here's what they
recommend. And I'll just kind of show
you as a starting point to get up off
the floor without using your hands or
coming up to your knees, criss-cross the
legs, and can you just sit down first?
How far can you sit down? Can you come
up here? And then what they want you to
be able to do is can you cross under?
And then maybe you give a little bit of
a push or a little bit of a swing
forward, but can you come up there
without using your hands? So, let's
tackle that part first. If that's a
complete chore for you, probably just
practice just squats. How far can you
take your squat down? Can you go into um
what they call an Asian squat? Sit down
real deep in through here. Maybe keep
your hands and your knees connected. I
like to push my hips back. This is a
good It looks weird. It looks kind of
wild and crazy, but that's something
nice to have uh help with that hip
mobility, but just doing squats here.
Maybe you find boxes, maybe a little uh
yoga block, maybe you find a book. Can
you just practice sitting on something
just a little bit elevated? Keep your
chest up and then come up there. So,
these are ways that you can practice
just that uh basic squat position. And
you saw that I did what they call the
pistol squat or the single leg squat.
You just get a chair and just practice a
how far down can I go? And then come up.
if you want to do that single leg uh
version of it right there. Next, I've
got what are called hip switches. These
help with some finesse, some agility,
and some mobility in the hips. First
option one, just lean back. You want to
get in through here, back and forth.
They kind of look like a little
windshield wiper movement in here to get
this. Just think
um kind of have your knees bent. And
then just fall one way. Let both knees
go this way here. and then let both
knees go this way here. So you can use
your hands for support behind you. You
can try to uh excel past or progress
past without using your hands. And then
finally, maybe you can try to keep a
little bit more upright. So don't bend
through here. Keep more upright. And
then do it here.
And then here for anybody who, you know
what, I don't necessarily need to be
able to get up without using my hands,
but maybe I could get to a knee and then
come up. What you can do is keep that
momentum going. over here and then come
up here.
>> Now, if you haven't already tried this
test, put it on pause and go ahead and
try it right now and then comment down
below if you're able to do it or not.
Let's talk about edema for a second. I
talked about that being a kidney
problem, a liver problem, or a heart
problem. You basically have a situation
where the blood is pooling in the lower
part of your body, and you desperately
need to push that back up with the
solius pushup as well as walking and
exercising. But don't forget potassium.
Potassium has a fantastic way of
offsetting sodium and pushing fluid out.
It's a natural diuretic. And we need
like 4700
milligrams of potassium every single
day. Rarely does anyone get that much.
It's a myth that potassium is bad for
the kidneys. What is true is if you have
latestage kidney disease, you should get
with your doctor before you start taking
any magnesium. But if you don't have
advanced kidney disease, taking more
potassium or even normal amounts of
potassium in electrolyte powder can
actually push out a good amount of this
fluid, but also go on low carb, do
intermittent fasting because
carbohydrates are one big cause of this
as well. So many people that go on a low
carb ketogenic diet, what they'll notice
within two days is they will drop 7 to
11 pounds. A lot of that's water weight
and that's the extra fluid that's on
their body that will go away. This is
not No, this is nitric oxide. Okay,
nitric oxide is a compound that helps
support the inside of the arteries that
endothelial layer. It helps to relax and
vasoddilate the arteries. And the
question is how do we increase it?
exercise.
The sun, infrared, UV increase nitric
oxide. Nasal breathing, breathe through
your nose, especially when you're
sleeping, can increase nitric oxide.
More vitamin D will help increase nitric
oxide. It's probably one of the most
potent things that you can do. If we're
talking about food, the top food that
will increase nitrates that will turn
into nitric oxide is arugula. That's the
type of salad that I consume. And also
beets. I take a organic beet juice
powder and I actually put it in cacao,
okay? Raw chocolate powder and I mix it
in some raw milk a little bit about uh 2
hours after I drink coffee in the
morning because that cacao has
polyphenols. Okay, right here that
greatly increase nitric oxide. And I
just combine it with the beets. It's a
real interesting flavor. I like it. And
uh if you put in water, it's a little
bit more nasty, but and in raw milk, it
seems to work out great. And I also put
it in the blender to blend it up really
nicely. But that's a super way to
increase nitric oxide. Also, magnesium
increases nitric oxide. The things that
decrease nitric oxide, smoking,
pollution, stress, being too sedentary,
alcohol, refined carbs and sugar, PPIs,
that's an ant acid, and also mouthwash.
All right. Next thing, I already talked
about this several times. Regular
consistent exercise. Let's say, for
example, you're a procrastinator or
let's say you don't have time to
exercise.
Micro exercises, very short exercise
throughout the day. Even if it's like
one to two minutes,
can actually be equivalent to a longer
period of exercise. So, just do as much
as you can. If you have a choice between
an elevator and walking the stairs, run
up the stairs. If you're on the computer
a lot, take frequent breaks and go do
some type of short exercise. It's
accumulative, but I want you to really
start increasing the amount of motion
you put in your body. And of course,
pair that with a good amount of sleep
because we want to recover from the
exercise. Now, if you are over the age
of 50, I briefly mentioned sarcopenia. I
have a much more thorough video on this.
I think it would be very beneficial for
you to watch. I put it up right here.
Check it out right now.